The Chinese military
says a
US spy plane
deliberately intruded into a Navy
training area last week in the South
China Sea
and is urging Washington
to restrain its troops.
This is a response to this video
released by the US.
It shows a Chinese fighter
jet cutting
right in front of an American spy plane
which had to fly through
the wake turbulence.
US officials called the fighter's move
unnecessarily aggressive.
CNN's Natasha
Bertrand is at the Pentagon.
The US says the fighter jet
was in international airspace.
Well, China is saying
this is an act of provocation.
It is important to understand
the context here
wider tensions
that have been brewing for a while.
But where are we in
terms of what both sides
are saying to each other?
Yeah.
So we actually just heard from US
Secretary of State
Antony Blinken, who spoke about this
to reporters,
telling them
that he does
believe that the Chinese pilot in
this instance was acting very dangerously
and that the US aircraft
was operating in international airspace.
But really underscoring
the fact
that this is exactly why the US wants
to keep
those military
to military channels
open with the Chinese
to avoid this kind of confrontation
and something
of course
that could lead to a dramatic escalation
between the two countries.
And he's saying that
because just this week
the US Defense Secretary,
Lloyd Austin
tried to set up a meeting
with his Chinese counterpart
and that was summarily
rejected by the Chinese.
One of many meetings
that the US has proposed in recent months
that the Chinese
have rebuffed
as a result of this heightening
tensions between the US and China
stemming from, for example.
Former House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi's
visit to Taiwan last year,
the incident where the U.S.
shot down
a suspected Chinese spy
balloon earlier this year,
and other episodes where the US has been
operating over the South China Sea
in a way
that China perceives
as violating its own territory.
Now of course the US does not
accept that.
They do not believe
that the South China Sea
is controlled by the Chinese.
But all of this
is really contributing to this.
This tension between the U.S.
and China.
And China is pushing back,
of course, this morning
with the foreign ministry
releasing a statement
saying that the US
was acting
in a provocative way
and the Chinese military
releasing a separate statement
saying that the US
had actually interfered
in their training exercises
So all of this really underscoring
for the US
why it's important to have this dialog
so that as two major
obviously military powers,
they avoid some kind of collision
that could then
spark a broader
conflict between the two countries.
This incident comes
at a very sensitive time.
So let's expand the conversation now
with CNN military
analyst General Wesley Clark.
He is a former
supreme allied commander of NATO's.
General, thank you so much
for being with us.
At the core of this incident
is the dispute between China
and the United States over the South
China Sea.
China says this happened
over their training ground.
The United States says
this was international waters.
I'm wondering what you make
of that dispute
Well, I think it's very
important for the United States
to continue
to insist
that this is international waters.
Something like a third of the world's
commerce goes through the South
China Sea.
That's not China's
territorial waters
under the Law of the Sea convention.
It is something that they declared was
a nice so-called nine dash line.
That was some government
road up
from China in 1948,
and they've suddenly seized on it.
This has gone on for several years.
They built up the atolls,
they put air bases on these atolls
after they promised they wouldn't.
They armed them with air
defense missiles,
after they promised President Obama
they wouldn't do that.
And so we're continuing to assert
freedom of navigation,
the seas and freedom
to do air reconnaissance in the skies.
And we must continue to insist on this.
Obviously,
one of many points of contention
between the two powers,
but perhaps
the most likely to lead
to a dangerous escalation and.
Right, because as we saw in this video,
the surveillance
plane encounters turbulence.
If there's any kind of miscommunication
or miscalculation
there could be a serious incident
That's right.
It could cause an incident.
And it's happened in the past.
Some 20 years ago,
an American
reconnaissance plane
had its wing
clipped by a Chinese fighter.
It had to make a forced landing
in Chinese territory.
The Chinese got an intelligence bonanza
out of that.
I'm sure our river joint crews
are very well aware of this incident.
They're very cautious.
And if anything were to happen,
of course,
the number one thing is
protect the intelligence
collection information
that's on board that rivet joint
that has to be protected at all cost.
But this is the nature
of the intelligence game.
We've got to fly there.
We've got to get their radars
to alert us.
We've got to pick up the emissions
from those radars
to understand
what's there and what
the threat might be.